[NOISE] Anybody there?
>> Is that you, Charles?
>> It is, maybe.
Who's asking?
>> It's me, Michael.
I was going to do another lesson.
>> Ooh, I like lessons.
How are you doing Michael?
>> Yeah, I'm doing all right.
>> I notice that my favorite
letter is on the screen.
>> Yes, Charles like the c.
Si si si, Senor.
Yes, so remember we had
a lesson that was a triple a.
So this is the triple c lesson.
>> That makes sense.
>> [LAUGH] It would make sense.
>> What about the triple b?
>> Triple b happened, but you have to
pay premium rates to see that one.
>> Nice, we quadruple your tuition.
>> No, there's no triple b
at the current time, but
we can think about that for later.
>> Maybe for our third class.
>> So, let's see.
So we talked about game theory.
And one of the cool
things about game theory,
is it let us reason about sequential
decision making in agents and
learning, in the context of there being
more than one of them in the world.
>> Right.
>> So
this is something that I
wrote in my dissertation,
is that in some sense MDPs,
are very solipsistic.
>> Wow, did you actually write that?
>> I did.
It's in my intro.
Do you know the word?
>> Of course I do.
>> Okay.
Do you want to define it for everybody?
>> No,
because that actually would be ironic.
>> Okay, fair enough.
So the idea of solipsism is that
you're the only thing in the universe,
everything else is just kind of there.
>> Yes.
>> But you're the only real thing.
And so one nice thing about
the game theory setting,
is it actually let's us admit
that maybe we're not alone.
So what I'd like to do in this lesson,
is actually dive in even more deeply to
that idea, and talk about how the MDP or
the mark off planning and
learning type framework,
can be adapted to be able to talk
about coordinating between agents,
communicating between agents, and
actually coaching between agents.
>> That sounds perfect.
That's actually the kind of
thing that I like to do, and
I like to think about
as part of my research.
So I'm looking forward to learning more.
>> Excellent.
So the way we're going to do that,
is actually look at different
ways that Markov models can be
kind of modified and redefined,
so that coordination and
communication, and so forth,
is a natural property in the model.
And we'll look at a couple
different models.
The first one is called Deck Palm PP's.
And the second one is called
Inverse Reinforcement Learning, and
they kind of get at these different
issues in slightly different ways.
>> Good.
I think, well we'll do that.
We'll talk about it some more, later.
>> OK.